Although it looks like an ant,
This is actually a spider.
Myrmarachne formicaria is a jumping spider
which has evolved its ant-like appearance
as a clever ruse to evade predators.
Similar evolutionary adaptations have been
found in the past,
such as butterflies that look like their less tasty cousins
and beetles that look like scary wasps.
Researchers looked at these tiny arachnids
with a high speed camera, and they found that
the spiders not only look like ants, but they
walk like ants too.
When marching along, the spider walks in a
winding wave motion,
which appears to potential predators as an ant following a trail.
It was previously thought that these ant-like
spiders don’t use their front legs at all
when walking. Instead, raising them up as pantomime antennae.
This new research shows that when viewed in slow motion, the spiders move
using all 8 legs, only raising their front
ones whenever they take a pause.
These pauses are another piece of mimicry.
The stops are consistently spaced out and
timed long enough to nail the illusion.
In most species of jumping spiders, raising
the forelimbs is a sign of aggression,
so in the future, researchers would like to see
if other spiders are fooled.
Do they see a threatening spider or just another
ant?